18 janvier 2020 alors que donald trump
est entièrement omnibulé par la
procédure de destitution engagées contre
lui au congrès son secrétaire d'état à
la santé alex hasard affirme l'avoir
informé du risque d'une pandémie de
coronavirus le président américain
aurait choisi d'ignorer son
avertissement quelques jours plus tard
un premier cas est dépisté dans l'ouest
à seattle le 22 janvier 2020 lors du
forum économique mondial de davos en
suisse le président américain s'exprime
pour la première fois au sujet du
coronavirus il déclare que les
etats-unis contrôlent la situation et
que tout va bien se passer
à la fin du mois de janvier une première
mesure est adoptée pour lutter contre le
virus
désormais toute personne ayant séjourné
en chine au cours des deux semaines
précédentes ne peut entrer sur le sol
américain
[Musique]
quelques jours après le premier décès
recensé lors d'une visite au centre pour
la prévention des maladies d'atlanta
donald trump temps à nouveau d'apaiser
les inquiétudes des américains
écoutez dans notre grand pays nous avons
240 cas la plupart de ces personnes vont
s'en sortir une grande majorité va s'en
sortir
nous avons eu 11 décès s'agisse en
grande partie de personnes âgées qui
sont sensibles je suppose que c'est
aussi le cas pour une grippe ordinaire à
la mi mars
changement de ton à washington le
président américain annonce
l'interdiction d'entrer sur le
territoire pour les européens venant de
l'espace schengen afin de lutter contre
la propagation du virus
dix jours plus tard les inscriptions au
chômage atteigne un nombre record aux
etats-unis avec 3,3 millions de demandes
d'allocations en une semaine fin mars
pour pallier la crise qui ravage le pays
le président américain annonce un plan
massif de soutien de l'économie
américaine une démarche inédite sous la
présidence de donald trump le 24 avril
les états unis passent le cap des
cinquante mille morts la veille le
président américain a fait une
déclaration aussi étonnante que
dangereuse qui a provoqué des réactions
dans le monde entier
je vois que le désinfectant assomme le
corps d'un virus en une minute
est ce qu'il ya un moyen de faire
quelque chose comme ça avec une
injection à l'intérieur ou presque comme
un nettoyage
comme vous le voyez ça pénètre dans les
poules ou et ça crée un énorme effet il
serait donc intéressant de le vérifier
[Musique]
alors que le chômage est au plus aux
états unis donald trump invité sur
foxnews justifie son action et se dit
très confiant pour l'année 2000 21
nous avions l'économie la plus forte de
l'histoire du monde la plus forte
économie que nous n'avons jamais eu et
nous avons dû la fermer ce qui est
artificiel
nous l'avons fermé artificiellement
c'est aux poivrons tous revenir ils
reviendront très bientôt
et l'année prochaine nous allons avoir
une année phénoménale selon de multiples
modèles épidémiologiques le pays
pourrait passer la barre symbolique des
cent mille morts au mois de juin